if the passport is it for the vast
majority of people except for some
people in the street for the vast
majority of people
the vaccination passport was very
popular and
gave them
a a great feeling of security when they
were going to the restaurant or the
movies
so why
if it were i know we're at 85
vaccination but if there's still a
threat in the future why are you
eliminating it
okay well i'll start because this is
really a recommendation of public health
but i think the conditions as dr abuelo
has done has changed and i said in my
statement we recognize that people
were really feeling confident at the
time at the time when we have delta as
opposed to omicron they were feeling
safe when they knew they can go to a
restaurant or to a public place because
that was protecting them but the thing
that's changed with tomica and i let dr
bolu complete that answer
they were feeling safer and they were
safer because with the vaccine
uh the contagiosity of delta virus or
the others that were before but namely
delta because we were in the last atom
period
it was very
uh very effective for that but with the
omicron which is a different virus it's
really different more contagious it is
so the the capacity of the double
vaccine to protect
for the contagiosity is really lowered
with three doses it's quite good but
it's really lowered with two doses so
and in fact right now we cannot move on
with a a
standardized
passport vaccine with three doses
because a lot of quebecers at least 2
million maybe 2.5 or 3 million has made
the infection recently so we suggest
them to wait until 8 to 12
weeks before being
up to dated with the third doses so it
was not applicable and that by that time
at the end of april may or even after
this wave should be
behind us there are people that would
that will accuse you of
doing this because of the protests are
you are you caving into public pressure
from the street no no not at all i think
we're doing it because it's the right
time to do it because it's safe for
public health and as i said i said i was
very clear it is there to last when
we'll need it
we will ask to be reestablished right
now the conditions are good and i think
this is the appropriate thing to do
right now record fletcher global
good afternoon
last week um
we had the the public health director
say that the passport was going to stay
in place until at least march 14th on
friday mr dubai during the
interpretation you said well we'll make
an announced announcement to that effect
in a couple weeks it has not been a
couple weeks it has been a couple days
and
now
we are we're asking questions here about
other things about what's gonna happen
in the future
uh is the mass gonna stay in place
is there a plan for a fourth
uh dose
you gave us answers but why should we
believe
what those answers are because
the way that you are giving us this
information changes so rapidly from day
to day i think that the opposition
parties today are their criticism this
morning was not what the decisions are
that you're making them but how you're
making those decisions is this the best
way to be making those decisions
well
let's be clear
um
we said that this passport
is there to stay when we need it i just
going to be very clear you want to go to
europe this summer
you'll have countries they will be
requiring this passport either at this
duty here or there so the passport is
there to stay in certain circumstances
and when i said that in the same week
remember i said there could be a sixth
wave and remember i said that in the
same sentence so let's be clear right
now we should be happy that we are able
to withdraw the passport because it
means it's going well it's going better
than a month ago
and it's like
wedding might be
going better even in a month from now so
let's
let's
take the joy
of the news we're getting today the
conditions are improving and if we can
limit the measure
and it's safe to do it i think that's
good news
okay i'm not sure you answered my
question but i have to move on to a
second uh topic uh doulas um
do you know that doula is someone who
helps a woman give birth yeah um they
are asking to be allowed back in
birthing centers and hospitals as a
second support person
um
because right now the women giving birth
are only allowed maybe their partner
their boyfriend or their husband they
would also like to be allowed to have a
doula that is not being
allowed at this point when can we expect
for doulas to be allowed back in the
birthing room i'm not sure if i can
answer that today i'll have to check
into this one i'm not sure if i can give
you the answer on that one
sunny cbc um i just would like to
clarify that's my first question
what's the clear scientific evidence
that the vaccine passport was efficient
to protect
the unvaccinated and the hospital
network
i'm sorry i missed the question that
what's your clear evidence dr bualo yeah
that the vaccine passport was actually
efficient to protect the unvaccinated
and the hospital network
during the american period or overall
like we're
we're trying to find a clear evidence
that the vaccine passport was actually
efficient that it made a difference so
do you have a clear evidence yes
absolutely we have clear evidence here
in quebec because it has
higher the the level of
vaccinated people uh before the i mean
right after the announcement and and
then after with the
implementation of the vaccine
the the vaccine passport so this has
been done and really obviously clarified
in quebec as in other jurisdiction
right now in the omicron situation
the um
obviously it seems that without a
passport you you would not you were not
able to get to restaurant and a large
surface
store so it lowered
the level of contact for those people
that were not already vaccinated so it
lowered the risk for them to get
infected and to
hide i mean increase the number of bed
needed
so so and and right now with those
numbers of beds that are lower than they
were and
there's kind of
acceptability to increase the risk of
those person to get infected
unfortunately because they're going to
be infected if they are not already they
are going to be and what was the game
changer
in the last few days
it was essentially the indicators of the
beds of the positivity of the test of
the other indicators that we have at
school for health workers so all those
are
going in the same same way lowering the
the the the significancy of the risk
globally for the population but not
enough to get rid of all the measures
but strong enough to begin to get rid of
those some like the vaccine passport for
those places
a lot of people are asking why we even
did this if we're taking it away now
what's your answer to that why did we do
the vaccine passport
well because it has been very helpful
quite helpful
it has allowed quebecers that were
vaccinated last fall last
fall to get back to a normal life
and
now that we have omicron and people that
have been contaminated we have a
different ballgame but i think we need
to
look back and say this was really
appropriate for a lot part of the
pandemic
and if we need to reinstate it we'll
reinstate it but right now that's the
best thing that we can do is to give
away those measures as much as possible
because we can't do it that's that's the
point